[Music]
a passionate crowd ahead of the World
Cup
[Music]
[Applause]
these are security officers taking part
in the exercise codename weapon which
means nation in Arabic
thousands of Civilian and military
officials from Qatar and 13 other
countries are doing the final stress
tests
Point Qatari Turkish unit is responding
to a bomb threat as the match continues
inside
they are pulling out all the stops to
prepare for any eventuality
all the while there will be charged
crowds inside and outside the stadium
and among them a few troublemakers
drunk and disorderly Behavior
and hooliganism concerns authorities at
football games
[Music]
and people would be Rowdy and that is
what security forces here are preparing
for how to handle those people and what
to do with them next
and people want to know how will the
security forces respond somebody who's
making trouble on the streets are you
going to beat them up are you going to
deport them what will you do everyone is
welcoming here in Qatar what we are
looking for is to show respect to our
culture and the tradition we are here in
this what's an exercise to overcome any
scenarios in in this case to make sure
that everyone is safe and secure in this
in our country and to reach the goal a
unique tournament ever
in addition to the 11 Ministries in
Qatar military and Security Experts from
Pakistan Saudi Arabia Jordan Kuwait
France Germany Poland Italy Spain the US
the UK and turkey are involved for those
who don't speak English translators will
ensure smooth coordination
[Music]
there are scenarios where buses are
being hijacked protests are happening
riots are happening some bombs are
exploding anti-drone operators are here
so it's all happening as if it was a
real life scenario during the tournament
one of the most secured locations here
in Qatar this is the command and control
center where all the action is taking
place experts from cyber security to
transport to anti-terrorism are all
stationed here and this is as close as
it gets to the real thing just ahead of
the World Cup as more than a million
people are expected to arrive for the
World Cup the message from the
tournament security committee is that
fans should feel safe with their
families and friends and people looking
to cause trouble should expect a
well-prepared security contingent
at the national Command Center